Spending just a few days
and weeks with these monkeys,
you start to see their
individual personalities
start to emerge.
Some of them are chatty,
some of them are kind of quiet,
others are just plain old mean.
And while it's
interesting to watch this
just from a human
observer perspective,
this is also really valuable
information for scientists.
By tracking individuals
from dawn until dusk,
everyday,
we can take this kind of
individual level information,
and learn about their
structure of their society.
Like who's related to whom,
who's higher ranking
or lower ranking,
or bits about if
they're stressed out
and what that means for
their internal state.
Unfortunately,
you can't embarrassingly
go up to a monkey
and ask for a reminder of what
it's name is if you forget.
So we invest a lot of
our time in the field
just trying to
learn their faces.
And this involves binoculars
standing really close
to something and
just staring at it.
For some monkeys this
is not that hard at all.
This guy right here is a face
that only mother
monkey could love.
And hopefully it doesn't
reappear in your dreams
a little bit later tonight.
This one you could
learn in five seconds.
Other animals you don't
have to rely on faces.
Topanga here on the
left has half a tail.
You can tell her from
twenty, thirty meters away.
But for the majority of them,
it comes down to looking at
little ridges in their face,
little moles they might have
or old scars from fights.
So we try to get as much of
this into our own mental banks
as we can but we do
rely on our notes.
And fortunately
Vivek and I are both
world class natural
history illustrators.
And we've filled
up our notebooks
with all sorts of
illustrations like this.
(laughter)
I think this is
Vivek's Mona Lisa here.
But jokes aside this is
a really valuable tool
to kind of remember the little
landmarks on a monkey's face.
And so we were the
first kind of cohort
of camp managers at Guassa.
So not only did we
have to learn monkeys
that had been identified
by Peter and Nga,
but we also identified a
bunch of new ones as well.
And on some days it
was really exciting.
You see a female
who's recognizable
and you might want to name her.
And this is what
happened with a juvenile,
I think back early
when we were there.
I was just standing there and
Vivek ran up really excitedly.
- [Vivek] Jeff I have
a new monkey for us.
- Oh really that's
very exciting Vivek.
Have you thought of a name yet?
- I think I wanna
name it Anusha.
- Anusha?
What does that mean?
- Well it's my sister's name
and I think she'll hate it.
(laughter)
- Perfect.
It's decided.
Normally we deliberate a
long time back and forth
cause these names
are in the record,
but that one was a
pretty easy call.
And it's been fun to track
Anusha over the years.
I know she was a juvenile
when we first identified her.
And now she's come into her own.
She has offspring and
some of the latest news
is that Anusha has a new male.
Which is very exciting.
But mothers have really
intimate relationships
with their infants,
they invest a great
deal of time with them.
Caring for them while
they still have to
go about their daily duties.
So you'll see a mother
holding an infant
like this with one hand,
while she's grabbing
grass with the other one.
It's always amusing when
she kind of crosses wires
a little bit and is whacking
her infant in the head
while she's putting
grass into her mouth.
But this relationship
between mother and infant
can last years.
As they grow up a bit more,
they'll give them rides
when they're tired.
Geladas can walk
several kilometers a day
in search of just the
right grass meals.
And they'll help
them jump across
little obstacles like this.
And when the kids need
help they'll let them know,
they'll stand there
screaming like (screaming).
And then it annoys
the mom just enough
she'll throw them on the back
and take them to the other side.
But it's not only
behavior that we focus on
while we're out there.
Knowing individuals
can unlock all sorts of
other information
sources as well.
You can tell Vivek's really
excited about this one.
I think he gave a little
teaser of it earlier.
And this is processing
a monkey fecal sample.
And when a monkey poops,
it gives you all
sorts of information.
It tells you what
it's been eating,
how well it's been
digesting that,
and other information
about it's internal state.
You can extract hormones
from poop as well.
So what we do is we follow
known individuals around
and then try to guess when
they're going to poop.
And Vivek and I are both
pretty competitive guys,
so this is a nice way
to pass those long,
endless days in the field.
You know who can end up with
the most fecal samples
in the morning?
Like who can have the
(bleep)iest morning?
I haven't talked about
this publicly before,
but I think Vivek's a
little bit better at this
than I am unfortunately.
So congratulations.
- [Vivek] Thank you.
- We can also look at
disease in fecal samples.
Because disease is an important
part of the geladas ecology.
About 30% of adults in
the population at Guassa
have parasitic swellings of
tapeworms from the genus Taenia.
And you can see
the swelling here
on the head of this monkey,
but they can be found
anywhere on the body.
At some point the swellings
will continue to expand
and occasionally rupture.
And it's a way that the
monkeys can get infected
and then lead to mortality.
Another kind of
outlet of competition
for Vivek and I related
to disease in us.
I lost about 30
pounds of body weight
while I was in Guassa
the first year.
And that had to
do with a variety
of kind of bacterial
and viral issues.
But we had this contest
running for some reason,
that we wanted to know
who could go the longest
without a shower.
So we went for I think two
months and then a couple days,
and I was supposed to
go back to the capital
right before Vivek so I broke.
And I was like all right fine,
this one's yours.
But this sort of
idiotic competition
led to other problems as well.
I think for both of us,
the flesh on our hands
started rotting off.
And falling off in big sloughs,
and we didn't really
know what it was.
So we wrote to some tropical
disease specialists,
and they didn't know
what it was either.
So we dumped some
balsamic vinegar on it,
and then we put gloves on
and it went away
after a couple months.
- Okay well.
So you just heard
about how Jeff and I
can get pretty competitive.
But that's mostly in
very trivial contexts,
because we had too
much time on our hands.
But male-male
competition in geladas
is actually no laughing matter.
Cause it has profound life
and death consequences.
I mentioned earlier
how each male gelada
is associated with
a group of females,
his harem.
Now this kind of demographic
imbalance creates a problem,
because it means there's
this pool of males
that aren't getting
mating opportunities.
So there's a huge amount of
competition for these top spots.
And evolution has basically
shaped gelada males
to reflect this
legacy of competition.
You can see that
in this male here.
First of all he's
big and imposing.
Male geladas are about twice
the size of the females.
If you're gonna be
fighting all the time,
it really helps to be big.
And they may look even
larger by this billowing cape
that you see right here.
The secondary sexual
characteristic.
This makes him
look more imposing
in these aggressive
interactions.
We also go back to
the chest patch.
So he has a very red
bleeding heart there.
And what that indicates
is that testosterone
is coursing through his veins,
he's ready to fight and
put it all out there.
What's truly spectacular though,
are the canines.
Gelada canine teeth
are one of the largest
among any primates
relative to body size.
And during the day when
we're out with the animals,
we can hear them grinding
their teeth against each other.
They're grinding that canine
against the bottom row
sharpening it for
subsequent conflict.
Now when fights erupt,
they can be pretty
crazy to watch.
And sometimes we even get hit
by monkeys that run into us.
But they can go on for hours,
if not days.
And eventually,
there's gonna be a winner.
So we observed a days
long interaction in 2011,
where at the end of it we
heard a bone crunching sound,
and one male limped
away totally bloody.
He disappeared after a few hours
and we never saw him again.
All the geladas become
really really upset
during these takeover events.
But it's the adult
females in the group
where there's a takeover
attempt that stand
to lose the most.
That's because in geladas,
because of the social
system they have,
you see a very disturbing,
distasteful behavior.
This is infanticide.
The killing of infants.
The way this works
is the new males
will grab an infant
off the mother's back,
and it will turn these
canines onto the baby.
Why are they doing this?
They're doing this because
that baby isn't theirs
and they wanna have their
own chance of reproduction.
So by killing this baby that
belonged to someone else,
they're able to stop the
mother from lactating
and have her start
her cycle again
so that he can
then mate with her.
So these males are
advancing their own
reproductive interests at
the expense of the females,
as well as at the
expense of other males
like the one you see here.
Terrified that his offspring
is about to get killed.
Now the females in the story
are actually not
passive players at all.
And it was recently discovered
that geladas have evolved
an amazing strategy
to counteract
these infanticidal
tendencies of the males.
So this was discovered
by our colleagues
at the University of Michigan,
working at the
Simian's research site,
with geladas in Ethiopia.
They discovered that
in geladas a phenomenon
known as the Bruce
effect is operating.
What this means is that when
there's a takeover in a group,
the females who are
pregnant will spontaneously
terminate their pregnancies.
Pregnancy and having a baby is
really energetically costly.
If that baby were to be born,
it would be killed the
day that it's born.
So they cut their losses
and terminate the pregnancy.
They start cycling again,
and can soon have a baby.
In the end,
they end up losing
little time overall
in their own
reproductive careers.
So this kind of drama it
almost seems more fitting
for Game of Thrones but this
is daily life for a gelada.
- This can be heavy
stuff to watch,
particularly when it's your
job to just take notes about it
or gather pictures of it.
But it's part of the job.
You sign up for
this when you engage
in kind of a long term
field project like this.
And it also comes
with other aspects.
When you're out in the
field for months at a time,
particularly in
alpine environments,
you're exposed to some
very extreme weather
that can be challenging as well.
So as we kind of
proceed through this day
in the life of a gelada,
in the early afternoon
it can turn from sunny
to just absolutely
dreadful very quickly.
And this has big impacts
on our data collection,
our ability to take photographs,
and our ability to stay sane.
Which is going to be
reflected shortly.
(thunder booming)
(heavy rain falling)
- Just another rainy day.
It's been raining about non-stop
since 5:45 this morning.
(heavy rain and hail falling)
Woah (bleep)!
(lightning crashing)
(heavy rainfall)
- [Vivek] You still
alive out there?
- [Jeff] Yeah it's quite a show.
What?
- [Vivek] Merry Christmas.
- Yeah yeah.
(laughter)
I think we've spent several
Christmases at the Guassa,
but it's always Christmas when
there's hail on the ground.
People ask me
sometimes if I'm afraid
of the monkeys attacking me,
or afraid of the animals kind
of turning on us out there.
But to be totally
straight with you,
it's the lightning.
I am deeply deeply
afraid of lightning
in alpine environments.
And rightfully so.
It's very dangerous.
So I get kind of a chill
seeing some of those videos.
They're fun to look back on,
but I don't want to spend
another rainy season
at the Guassa.
And to be fair,
the geladas probably don't
wanna spend another rainy season
at the Guassa either,
but they don't have as
much choice as I do.
It's a very exposed place,
there's nowhere to hide.
So they just have to sit
out there and take it
like your research assistant
sitting right there as well.
And they'll bundle together
and just wait it out.
Some days they won't even come
up from their cliff edges.
And they can be difficult
to find for days
or weeks at a time.
But with these rainy periods
which can last for days
or weeks or months,
there's kind of a
seasonal cycle to it,
the highlands transform.
They become very lush.
On the Guassa,
the grass grows green and tall.
And down on the farms
the crops start growing
and the livestock
start to fatten up
on the really nutritious
grass that exists down there.
There's more
livestock in Ethiopia
than in any other country,
yet it's rare to see any
livestock on the Guassa itself.
And this is by design.
For centuries,
and we're talking
hundreds of years here,
the local community has
limited access to the Guassa,
except during an
occasional time of need
every couple of years.
And what this means is that
they're trying to protect
their most precious
resource on the Guassa.
And that's the grass.
The word Guassa is derived from
the Amharic word
for festuca grass,
which you see growing here.
Aside from being a
potential buffer zone
for grazing animals
and livestock,
the grass itself is a
very useful resource
for the local people.
They use it to thatch the
roofs of their houses,
they use it to build ropes,
line their floors,
build brooms and many
other tools as well.
And for centuries enforcement
of this closure of the Guassa
from grazing or for grass
cutting was associated with
the Ethiopian Orthodox Church.
This is a really important
institution in the highlands.
And it ties in with traditions
that go back more
than centuries.
Enforcement could be very
severe however many years ago.
If you were caught illegally
grazing your cattle,
it would be killed on the spot.
If you cut grass
without permission,
your house would be burned down.
In recent years a more secular,
and less severe version of
this enforcement has emerged
and now it's being
led by this man.
Admassu Getaneh.
Who's a former soldier
turned conservationist.
He leads patrols of local
farmers from the community
on the Guassa day and night
looking for unwelcome outsiders.
People that are
poaching it's resources,
cutting it's grass,
cutting down it's
shrubs to make charcoal.
And for centuries,
the fact that they've been
preserving this region
to protect it's grass has had
the unintended consequence
at least initially,
of preserving it's wildlife.
This is not the case
throughout many of the other
parts of the
Ethiopian highlands,
where farming and overgrazing
has led to erosion
and just the real change in
the land cover that you see.
This is outside of Guassa,
and this is a photograph
of Ryan Burke,
another former camp manager
from the Guassa Gelada
Research Project.
Over the past several years,
along with several of
his Ethiopian colleagues,
they've been scouring
the highlands
looking for information
about geladas.
Censusing them and figuring
out what their distribution is.
And they've created this map.
This is the most up
to date understanding
that we have of
gelada distribution.
They're found only in Ethiopia,
along these high
altitude ridge lines
associated with the
Great Rift Valley.
And the gorges that
go inland from it.
This is a much reduced range
from what people thought
geladas existed in,
based on some preliminary
surveys 40-50 years ago.
And right now Ryan and his team
are still working
on these surveys,
there's a couple areas left
to go but this is really
rewriting what we know
about gelada distribution.
The Guassa is located
right in the center.
And it stands apart
as I mentioned,
as the most ecologically
pristine elements
where geladas are found.
And with an ecologically
intact environment
comes other things.
In this case predators.
It's very rare to see a predator
out in the daylight
in the highlands.
This is only one of a
couple sightings I had
of a serval cat
over my time there.
But there are also hyenas,
and leopards,
and other mammalian predators
in this environment.
Despite the fact that you
don't often see predators,
they still have a massive impact
on the behavior of this species.
Geladas are always on edge.
And you'll hear
alarm calls coming up
maybe several times a day,
where geladas will
stop what they're doing
and scan the environment.
Devoting all their
attention to assessing
whether there's a
threat in the area.
Most of the time these
are false alarms.
But they have good
reason to be worried.
I had no idea that
I was standing just
a couple meters away
from a serval that was
hiding in this bush.
And neither did the female
who was carrying this infant.
I was standing there and
I saw a flash of movement,
and heard geladas
starting to scream.
I spun around and kind
of threw my camera up,
and took this photograph.
A second later,
the serval was gone,
buried in this St.
John's wort thicket.
You can tell this infant's
just a couple days old,
still has the
umbilical cord attached
and a dried out placenta on it.
The herd was screaming
and fled back
towards their sleeping cliffs,
followed by their mother
who was giving her
own mournful calls.
Even if geladas don't
experience a predation event,
just seeing a predator
is often enough
to send the herd fleeing
back towards the cliffs.